so we've talked a lot about the benefits
of feedback control over something like
open loop
and in particular we listed them before
as stability so it's possible with
feedback of your system to change the
eigenvalues to design the eigenvalues of
your closed loop system for example to
stabilize an inverted
an unstable system like the inverted
pendulum
but we also said that one of the
benefits of feedback is
uncertainty in the plant so if i have
some uncertainty in my model for my
system
open loop is going to be pretty bad and
it's not going to take into account
any measurements to correct that
uncertainty whereas feedback will use
measurements of the output of the system
to correct the feedback if i have an
uncertain model
and it's also useful if there are
disturbances so if my system's actively
being kicked or pushed in a way that's
hard to predict
then closed-loop measurement based
feedback control is going to be better
than open loop
and so we've spent a lot of time talking
about stability in the context of linear
quadratic regulators and common filters
but we haven't talked so much about
uncertainty and disturbances
so i'm going to cook up a really simple
example system today that motivates the
benefits of feedback over open loop
control
when you have a system that has
uncertainties and disturbances
so the simplest model that we're going
to be working with is essentially a
cruise control model
okay so the automobile um
cruise controller
uh and so the idea here is that u is
essentially how much gas i give the car
or maybe gas and break
um and then y is the speed of the car
and i might want to track a reference
speed so let's say i set my cruise
controller at 60 miles per hour i want
my controller to
to track um
60 miles per hour despite uh if my model
of the car is bad and if i have
disturbances like like hills
okay so we're going to be doing a cruise
controller
for a car
and the car could be on some rough
terrain where there might be
disturbances okay so i think of
for example if there are rolling hills
and i'm trying to track a speed those
are like disturbances that are going to
add and subtract velocity
um that open loop control wouldn't know
about
also if there's high winds or you know
if my tires are a little bit miss out of
alignment that could be a disturbance or
a model uncertainty
okay so the first thing we're gonna do
is think about what is our nominal model
for for the system and a really crude
model for your car
could be that y equals let's say two
times u now i haven't given this any
units and
um you know but let's say i measure that
if i put my foot down one unit of gas
i get two units of speed out so i put it
down a little bit and i get a certain
amount of um
of steady state speed on a flat
flat road okay so this is essentially my
model
now let's think about what open loop
control would do
to solve a reference tracking problem so
what is
u
open loop okay so let's define a few
variables let's say that i have some
some reference r some reference speed
that i'm trying to track okay
what does open loop control do
so if i want y
to equal
r
with open loop control i'm going to say
okay what is u equal u equals
uh
r divided by 2.
that's the open loop model because i
know that if i put in
r over 2 into my model i get out y
equals r which is what i want i want my
output velocity let's say this is the
actual speed
let's say this is gas and break
break p-r-a-k-e
uh then the open loop strategy not
knowing anything about disturbances just
based on my model would be
take the reference velocity that you
want to be going and divide by two
because my
model amplifies you by a factor of two
okay that's the open loop
now
this is a pretty bad
controller for a lot of reasons so
namely uncertainty in the model and
disturbances so if my model was actually
y equals u let's say this is an old car
maybe um
i need to clean my fuel injector my fuel
injectors and my tires are slightly out
of alignment maybe the pressure in my
tires is a little deflated
um
maybe my car is inefficient and y is
actually just equal to u so it's like
half as punchy as my model started out
then my open loop control is not going
to get me nearly to my desired speed r
it's going to get me to r over 2.
so if the actual system differs from
this model
my open loop control has no way of
correcting for that
moreover
if i have
let's say that i have my actual model
i'll write that here so true model
is y
equals one times u
plus disturbance
okay so this is my model for the car
this is what my uh true let's say true
car not true model
this is my true automobile my true car
so if my model is y equals 2u so i
have a bad model and i don't take into
account disturbances then open loop
gives me this controller but if my true
car model is y equals u plus d
notice that
y
open loop
is equal to my reference speed over two
plus disturbances okay so i have the
wrong
i i'm only tracking 50 of my reference
velocity and all of the disturbances
pass right through to my actual speed y
so if i'm on rolling hills my open loop
controller doesn't take that into
account at all
okay
so what do we do in practice so in
practice what we do is we close the loop
okay and we all know this at this point
so what we do
is we close the loop with some
controller k
and what we do is we say
i'm going to measure the actual speed of
my car so if i'm on this rolling hill
and i'm speeding up i'm going to measure
that in y
i'm going to feed that back and i'm
going to subtract it from my reference
speed
and then the difference of those two is
going to be some error signal epsilon
okay and now what i'm trying to do is
i'm trying to choose k to make epsilon
small
okay this is essentially proportional
feedback control so i'm going to just
call this
proportional
feedback
it's proportional because k is just a
number it's like a constant times
epsilon so it's proportional to the
error and feedback because i'm measuring
y and feeding it back to get this
measured error epsilon
okay
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to actually compute what is the
true y closed loop with this feedback
law and we're going to write it down as
a function of reference and disturbance
okay so remember the true car is y
equals u plus d
and now that i wrap this feedback around
we're going to say y
equals and let's say that the true car
is
there's some
plant model some transfer function model
which is i'm going to call it p
and i'm keeping this pretty vague here p
is a number it literally means in
reality
y is 1 times u
but later we're going to replace this
with a transfer function we're going to
allow this to have some dynamics maybe y
you know has there's some time delay
from when i hit the gas to when the car
speeds up okay so but i'm keeping it
vague p
is just a symbol here k also you know is
going to be a number now but we can make
it have dynamics later
and so i'm going to write down a couple
of a couple of
math facts
so you closed
loop you closed loop
is equal to
k
times epsilon
k times my error
which i can also write as k times
r minus y pretty straightforward okay
and then i can say that y closed loop
is equal to
p
times u so i pass u through p p times u
which equals
p times all of this stuff okay
and it equals p times u
plus disturbance remember we still have
disturbances so somewhere in here
uh there's a
there's a d that's getting added in we
have a disturbance that's coming into
the system
okay so now the trick is we're going to
solve for the y closed loop as a
function of r and d and we're going to
see how this proportional feedback
brings y closed loop close to the
desired reference even if my model was
bad and i have disturbances
okay
so
doing this i'm going to plug this
expression for u into u here
and i'm going to get that this equals p
times k
times r
minus p
times k times y
plus d and this is why closed loop so
let's not drop the closed loop
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to bring all of my y closed loops
over to the same side and solve for y
closed loop
so i'm going to have identity matrix
sorry this is one in this case because
it's a single system
but in the multiple input multiple
output that would be identity matrix 1
plus pk
times y closed loop
equals
pk times my reference
plus my disturbance okay and the last
thing i have to do
is just solve for y closed loop equals
pk over 1 plus pk
times the reference
let me switch to something brighter here
plus 1 over 1 plus pk
times the disturbance
okay
so this term tells me how good my y
output my output speed matches my
reference
speed and this term tells me how much
disturbances get reduced by effective
control
okay so now remember
the model for p was that p equals two so
the model
uh
so model p
equals two
but the true car system had p equals one
okay and remember open loop just uh
inverts this
p and finds the u that would uh that
would give you the perfect reference
tracking if the actual car acted like
the model
so
notice here
that if my p is not what i think it
should be
then
i can still
get away with having a really big
proportional feedback k and making this
thing look like one so we want this to
look like one we want this to equal one
because if this equals one then we have
really good reference tracking then my
output speed equals my reference speed
and we want this
to equal zero because if i have a
disturbance i want whatever feedback
multiplying it to make this as small as
possible
and so you'll see pretty quickly that
the best way to make this as close to
one and this is close to zero
is a really big k so big
k
works that's the the upshot is that if i
choose k really really large let's say k
equals a hundred
so if k equals a hundred
then i have something like a hundred
divided by a hundred and one this is
really close to one
so this is only off my my actual speed
is only off by from my reference speed
by about one percent
and i've reduced disturbances by about a
factor of a hundred one over one hundred
and one okay so i've reduced my
disturbances by a factor of 101
and my true speed is tracking my
reference speed
very close within one percent
so in contrast
remember my open loop controller was off
by 50 the reference track the reference
velocity was off by 50 because my model
was bad and my disturbance wasn't
reduced at all
so for example if i have this rolling
hill here
all of that rolling hill is going to
pass directly into my speed i'm going to
speed up and slow down and speed up and
slow down if i just hold my foot at a
constant amount of gas
but if i measure my speed and i feed
that back and i
pump out gas based on the difference
between my speed and the desired speed i
can speed up on the downhills and i can
break sorry i can speed up on the
uphills and i can
brake on the downhills and i can
maintain
within one percent
of my desired reference reference speed
okay
so this is an example where we can
handle model uncertainty and
disturbances by taking measurements and
feeding them back in proportional
control
okay so in the next video we're going to
take this exact same system and we're
going to code it up in matlab
with some numbers and we're going to
plot and show that closed loop gets much
much closer than open loop to the
desired reference speed all right thank
you